in the piece of his countryside retreat
boris johnson is building his defenses
calling mps and preparing for a report
into allegations of lockdown breaking
parties that will determine how much
longer he gets to call this prime
ministerial residence his own
down the road in his outer london
constituency voters are scathing on a
scandal the government has struggled to
shift the party stuff just messed it all
up so he won't get a second book i like
that to play everyone i don't think
that's good at all it doesn't look good
at all it's quite embarrassing we should
stay
yeah he's done a good job he should go
yeah definitely he was partying during
the lap locked down and he was being
irresponsible
then there's this the reports of which
i'm aware would seem to constitute
blackmail allegations from a senior mp
of intimidation and blackmail against
mps trying to remove boris johnson no
sight of william rag in his greater
manchester constituency today but he has
said he'll be meeting the police next
week to discuss the accusations
this barrister says the authorities will
need to decide whether it's in the
public interest to pursue a conviction
that's going to be a very tricky
decision for any prosecutor because of
course there's this conflict between the
workings of parliament and the legal
system which has always been a problem
but right here we're seeing the police
potentially becoming involved right in
the middle of the heart of parliament
the heart of the government process
attempts to scare politicians into line
here are nothing new but a legal
intervention could open up further cases
the argument over the heavy-handed
treatment of mps is part of a broader
disintegration in the relationship
between boris johnson and some in his
party to try to combat this the prime
minister has reassembled a team of close
allies to try to rally support and
protect his position if or quite
possibly when a formal attempt to remove
him materializes
this former mp who was kicked out of the
tory party over a brexit vote says the
actions of the government whips in
enforcing party discipline is not a
matter for the police
people know that the whips will use
strong arm tactics if i can put it that
way to try and get people to vote their
way
and that is the way politics is and
boris johnson and his whips wanting to
get through next week they want to avoid
a leadership election so they'll use the
tactics that will get them through
that
issue whether it poisons relationships
with a large part of their party
long term whether
revenge is a dish that will be eaten
cold by some of the bench mps that
they've managed to
get into line this time is we'll have to
wait and see boris johnson is used to
escaping from tight spots but sue gray's
inquiry into downing street parties will
test him to his limits its publication
next week a moment of grave danger for
one of the great political survivors